[Music]
we're going to open this hour with our
friend scott in indianapolis indiana
scott welcome to the ramsay show
oh thank you my wife and i have uh
not necessarily disagreement but just
trying to get uh guidance on
how much for a new car is is appropriate
to spend okay talk us through this
what's your financial situation
well uh we're debt-free and we'd be
paying with cash
um
and uh we generally drive cars into the
ground so i've had mine for 12 years
and bought it two years
it was two years old when i bought it
and
looking at
stepping up a bit but a lot's changed in
the world in 12 years since we've bought
a car
so just trying to get a handle on
how much to spend what are you looking
at
well
i'd like to get a alfa romeo whoa
hey now which uh
you know it's a pretty car
um
now i currently drive a five series bmw
okay
but i got the tax uh appraisal and it's
worth like four thousand bucks now and
like well you know maybe i need a a new
car because i've had this one for 12
years how much is the alpha romeo you're
looking at
i'd be about 90. oh
okay all right and you've got the cash
to pay for it
yes
where are you guys at in the baby steps
you've been following that plan you said
you're debt free do you have a paid for
house
yes yes so uh
i first heard dave in 1998
and uh been following the plan since
then so
we have a net worth about three and a
half million and well that changes the
equation my friend way to go and what's
your income
currently uh
yeah probably about five a year five
hundred thousand a year
yeah yeah and so your wife is saying
ninety thousand because you've never
you've lived like no one else
i mean
you you're you're it's unbelievable so
what's the disagreement
she just
well yeah i mean you know our first
house was only
like uh
uh 200 and uh you know and we've been
looking at cars and a lot of the cars
don't cost what they cost 12 years ago
right brandon this is a really nice car
but she's emotionally grappling with the
fact that a car could cost ninety
thousand dollars and you want it
well yeah i i think that's it what's the
number that she's okay with if it's if
90 is a bit much in her eyes what's the
number she goes i'm fine with this
number
well yeah i'm trying in case she hears
this later i don't want to
hear it from her but you know i spent 30
on the last car and so she's like well
why not it's been 35. and but that
doesn't go as far as it used to no and
uh as a percentage of our net worth
you know we're worth like 10x what we
were yes
yeah on the ramsey side you guys are in
in amazing shape and there's no problem
with getting this 90 000 car but this is
not really a financial question this is
more of a relational question how do i
get my wife on the same page
so that i can get the car
yeah i'm not even necessarily trying to
you know it's just you know how you know
we didn't grow up with this kind of
money right so uh
you know on one hand it
the intellectual side of it's pretty
straightforward because i can do ratios
and why not but well you've listened to
dave a long time george you can refresh
him let's just play out the the
percentages
yeah you've got multi-million dollar net
worth and you're saying hey can i spend
a tiny tiny fraction of that on a car
that we're paying cash for and is well
under half of our income
in that scenario it's hard to look at
the math and go wow this is an
outrageous expense but i get that your
wife she remembers the old days and
she's going man that's way too much to
be spending on a car but you guys have
worked you've sacrificed you've lived
like no one else and now is the part
where you get to live like no one else
how old are you scott
um
about 50
just turned 50. it's hard to say out
loud i know i could tell you were like
about 50.
uh that's like we're all it's all we
were nine we're like i'm nine and a half
thank you very much just rounding yeah
you know what if you said your wife's
fine and it's not getting her on board
issue it's just you wanted to double
check your percentages well you got your
answer i'd buy the car
all right well uh what does she get out
of the deal
well i'm trying to get her a nicer car
i'd like to get her a
a
land rover or something but uh hers is
not as many miles on his mind she she
drives the kids around so i don't mind
what i drive but i figure if we're going
to get something new we should get
something good well let her dream a
little bit you guys have done so well
does she like buying stuff or is she
very still very diligent and frugal and
says ah that's that's a waste
yeah i mean really the only thing we
splurge on is trips so we like to get
the kids out and travel but we we just
don't spend a lot
well take her on a nice trip yeah i mean
have you driven this uh this alpha romeo
have you taken it out for a spin
well i i i i will i haven't yet
i'm very weary of car fever so
well that's been inoculated against car
fever i get it and i think you've been
very disciplined i'm actually going to
recommend that you know why don't you go
out and drive a 60 000 car
you know
i understand the 90 000 alpha romeo and
the percentages and you're there but you
know just try several things um
but you don't have anything to be afraid
of making the kind of money you're
making and you're debt-free and the
percentages here say it's good but you
know go drive the thing you know um
they'll let you do it you got the cash
you can show them it's right there in
the bank
um drive a few drive a few other amazing
things get it out of your system a
little bit and then decide what you want
to do but you know you've done the right
things and now at almost 50 uh or you
are 50. i can't remember what he said
you know you uh
you've earned it and um
you two got to be on the same page
though you know what i mean like
agreed yeah and that's the key i think
as long as you do that um that's
fantastic yeah great question scott
fantastic job you guys have put yourself
in the face i was hoping he had a story
for us george well he'll come back he'll
call us back you know those cars by the
way there's a reason they cost what they
cost what is that high performance is
that it
i always thought it was great branding
and marketing no no uh
for father's day about five years ago
stacy and the kids surprised me
and i got to do seven laps on a road
course
in a lamborghini we're talking a
racetrack here oh yeah real racetrack
lamborghini diablo okay
there's a difference i was terrified and
the instructor's in the car with me so
he's like look it's one of those fake
stuff he's like this is gonna feel like
you're gonna flip the car but it will
not flip you gotta trust me i'm like i
don't trust you man
i mean the speed and the power in these
cars how fast did you take it uh
honestly george i was so focused on the
road i never looked you never looked
down i listen was it so exhilarating and
terrifying at the same time was it 100
oh yeah on the straightaways i got it up
to 200. very impressive
well you guys like your cars i'll give
you that
but do it with cash people do it the
right way do not go into debt and do it
like scott did completely debt-free way
to go with a multi-million dollar net
worth half america's going yawn scott
buy the car
do it man
this is the ramsay show